[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec philippe
guiguen mer des clayes-sous-bois bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes donc le le maire
dé des clayes-sous-bois depuis les
dernières élections vous avez été élu au
deuxième tour en juin dernier après une
campagne qui semble-t-il a été assez
difficile il faut dire que la majorité
municipale de vouziers parti depuis
trois mandats dont deux comme comme
premier adjoint était divisée est ce que
vous direz que derrick aujourd'hui au
fond les les plaies de cette campagne
sont cicatrisées
je ne sais pas si les plaies sont
cicatrisées mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
et encore plus dans les circonstances
auxquelles nous devons faire face il
faut se projeter sur l'avenir
et puis faire faire un peu fi du passé
alors cet entretien on enregistre alors
que bâle et des rumeurs de on évoque
très clairement la possibilité d'un
reconfirmant quels sont les problèmes
que posent un maire comme vous êtes
justement la situation sanitaire et le
risque de confinement alors
effectivement depuis depuis mon élection
nous avons enfin j'ai à faire face comme
mes collègues à la situation pandémique
ce qui veut dire que nous avons beaucoup
moins de possibilités de proximité avec
avec la population au travers des
différentes manifestations nous avons
tout ce qui concerne la culture qui est
qui est fermé comme dans comme dans tout
notre pays ce qui fait que l'aspect
l'aspect ce lien social avec la
population est vraiment un problème sur
le sur le sur le quotidien après il ya
tout l'aspect social au travers d des
entreprises qui peuvent être être fermée
dans pour certaines certaines de
celles-ci et les conséquences pour
l'heure pour leurs employés
pour l'instant nous ne vivons pas trop
au quotidien mais mais les conséquences
je les crains jeu l'écran pour pour la
suite c'est pour plus tard que ça risque
d'être d'autant que vous avez beaucoup
défendu notamment les petits commerçants
qui sont évidemment les premiers
atteints par parra 7 cette crise
sanitaire et les est ce que on parle
beaucoup d'un abattement d'une façon
générale de la population est ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous ressentez
face à ces mesures
évidemment c'est très très dur pour
toutes tout à fait je le ressens je le
ressens au quotidien je pense qu'il ya
eu il ya eu à peu près trois phases dans
la période que nous avons que nous
venons de passer le premier confinement
à partir à partir de mars ou qui a été
qui a été soudan mais mais les gens ont
compris et ont accepté et je pense que
les français il faut quand même
reconnaître qu'ils acceptent beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ils sont ils sont
très très docile ensuite il ya eu la
réouverture et là on ya peut-être un peu
trop de liberté on pensait que la
pandémie était derrière nous ce deuxième
confinement partiel à partir de novembre
où là on s'est aperçu que
malheureusement la pandémie n'était pas
n'étaient pas derrière nous mais ça se
passait relativement correctement
par contre là l'hypothèse de ce
troisième confinement quelqu'un quel
qu'en soit la forme
je sens que dans les esprits ces
tendances étendu s'est tendu par
toulouse partout on est un petit peu que
sous une coque sur jeu comme une cocotte
minute et j'espère que que y aura pas
d'explosion j'espère dans parmi vos
projets il y avait il ya la création
d'une maison interdisciplinaire de santé
est ce que justement c'est ce genre de
deux structures pour aider dans face à
notamment une crise sanitaire comme
celle là alors je pense qu'effectivement
c'était c'était un des points un des
points importants de notre de notre
projet municipal projet sur lequel
d'ailleurs nous continuerons
à avancer malgré la situation
aujourd'hui aussi bien en parallèle avec
le département qu'avec le
l'agglomération donc ça pourrait être un
point important sur sur le quotidien
parce que ce qui importe à la population
c'est le vécu le vécu du quotidien
d'ailleurs à propos de de ce vécu du
quotidien et des problèmes sur la
vaccination auxquels font face beaucoup
de notre faire beaucoup de nos
concitoyens je pense qu'on ne peut que
saluer la façon dont le centre de
vaccination au vélodrome de saint
quentin a été organisée au bénéfice de
la population du territoire
même si on doit reconnaître mais ça
c'est absolument pas du fait de du
territoire il y à il ya très très peu de
doses de vaccin puisque il n'y en a que
850 départs par semaine mais au moins le
territoire est efficace par rapport à
ceux à ce niveau de vaccination les
habitants des clés c'est plutôt au
vélodrome 2-2 saint quentin ils devront
se faire vacciner un cantique pour rolf
est ravie d'abord il ya eu un très très
bon entente sur les douze maires delà de
la commune de saint quentin pour
l'organisation et l'affectation d'une
partie de ses actions alors vous avez
été je lisais pendant longtemps adjoint
aux finances donc c'est un problème qui
vous tient à coeur
alors comment on fait alors que
justement l'impact des mesures
sanitaires
ce chiffre pour vous en perte de
centaines millions deux millions de
millions d'euros en tout cas centaines
de milliers d'euros que les dotations de
l'état ont baissé je crois qu'il ya eu
moins de 2 millions 600 mille en 2020
comment on fait pour gérer une ville
face à ses difficultés financières
alors nous sommes nous sommes face à des
choix et je pense qu'il faut que la
population comprenne que l'on ne peut
pas tout faire et qu' il faut faire des
choix aussi bien dans l'équipe et
vis-à-vis de la population puisque moins
d'un de mes objectifs est de continuer à
maîtriser la fiscalité locale puisque
depuis maintenant 10 ans safra 11 ans
parce que c'est aussi ce que je
proposerai en 2021
nous avons gelé gelé nos autos communaux
donc à partir du moment où vous avez
moins de recettes
on ne peut dépenser ou affectés que les
recettes que nous avons donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya des choix à faire en
interne des pistes de recherche
d'économies un petit peu partout mais
même si si nous nous faisons ça au
quotidien
à terme ça c'est un des limites donc ce
que j'espère c'est que sur le sur le
moyen terme nous ne serons soyons pas
obligés de diminuer trop trop de service
il ce qu'il faut c'est pour l'instant
les adapter mais vous ne tenez pas
d'accroissement au fond de la pression
fiscale race est annoncée c'est un de
mes objectifs
en plus des objectifs avec la réforme de
la taxe de la taxe d'habitation
il y a plus la pression fiscale ne peut
être posée que sur la taxe foncière
c'est à dire une partie de la population
et nous n'avons plus de levier fils de
levier fiscal sur la taxe sur la taxe
d'habitation alors la ville des
clayes-sous-bois compte combien à peu
près 18 mille cinq cents habitants ça
diminue un peu moins de 10 un peu moins
de 18 mille habitants comme un dément
désuet d'habitants et vous même vous
êtes plutôt engagée à lui garder un
visage humain c'est vrai que c'est une
ville d une croissance très forte en
dans les vingt derniers
année alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
le garder un visage humain
aujourd'hui il n'a pas une croissance
très fort du cependant c'est dans ces 20
dernières années mais puisqu'on est
passé d'un peu plus de 17000 à 18000
maintenant un peu moins de 18 mille
alors regarder le visage eu le village
humain c'est-à-dire que vif il faut
qu'il y ait un renouvellement urbain il
y a nécessité d'avoir de nouvelles
constructions mais absolument pas de
surdensification pourquoi il ya
nécessité de nous de nouvelles
constructions c'est que vous avez des
anciens qui sont dans des dans des
maisons individuelles qui veulent aller
dans des dans des appartements à présent
malheureusement il y a des enfin dans
dans des couples qui se séparent donc
c'est le phénomène qu'on appelle de
desserrement et si on ne veut pas avoir
une baisse de la de la population il il
est nécessaire d'avoir un minimum d'un
minimum de construction
mais ces constructions tout cela doit
être raisonnée c'est pour ça que nous
avons lors du dernier conseil municipal
relancé en p1 à notre paix lui et puis
également créer un périmètre de
sauvegarde pour éviter que les
promoteurs puissent s'emparer de
certaines parties de la ville où je sais
très bien qu'il faudra reconstruire un
petit peu mais certainement pas dans les
proportions dans les proportions que
souhaitent les promoteurs me dé rsa un
moon évidemment on parler de la
situation qui est très complexe dans
votre programme il y avait environ 143
engagement alors vous n'en est qu'au
tout début de votre mandat
est-ce que vous avez l'espoir de pouvoir
mener à bien la plupart de ses
engagements en tout cas oui oui j'espère
mais c'est se sait sur la longueur que
l'on que non que l'on jugera d'autant
plus avec 20,7 cette pandémie est là et
la difficulté de 10 liés au démarrage
mais sur la longueur j'ai très bon
espoir de fin de conflit rla la majorité
de ses engagements et un certain nombre
sont des gens vraiment des engagements
forts et c'est aussi pour cela qu'il
faudra se focaliser dans les dents les
uns dans les années à venir
un mot pour terminer sur l'entreprise
atos cliquez sur votre territoire
il ya eu des atteintes physiques fin des
concerts sur un certain nombre de deux
personnes qui devaient travailler dans
cette entreprise voit ce qu'on en est
actuellement à l'or est effectivement il
ya eu il ya eu ces problèmes de cancer
sur deux sur du personnel avec quatre os
nous fonctionnons vraiment en toute
transparence
il ya des enquêtes qui ont été qui ont
été menées des mesures qui ont été
faites nous avons eu tous les résultats
de ces mesures avec avec la direction
d'atos et pour aller un peu plus loin
nous avons sollicité également la rs
pour faire des mesures complémentaires
sur l'environnement et j'ai même demandé
qu'il ya des mesures qui soient faits
sur l'ensemble de la ville donc dans les
semaines à venir je pense que nous
aurons les résultats de ces mesures et
tout cela sera communiqué en toute
transparence de la part de la
municipalité comme atos l'a fait la fed
vis à vis de nous l'objectif est de des
transparents pour la population et et je
l'espère et je le pense la rassurer
merci beaucoup philippe gay games va
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion
évidemment de se retrouver de reparler
et des clayes-sous-bois et puis
peut-être aussi d'universités parce que
c'est aussi votre rôle à la communauté
d'agglomération
merci beaucoup projet merci beaucoup au
revoir avant
[Musique]